[Music]
so in modern america if you point out
that biological sex is a physical
reality you can be fired from your job
the washington post will send a reporter
to your house to intimidate you but it
doesn't change anything denying reality
doesn't change reality you could say
gravity isn't real but if you jump off
the roof of your garage you're still
gonna get hurt
and that's true for biological sex it is
in fact real whether the authorities
admit it or not officials in new jersey
are learning that lesson this week two
female inmates at a supposedly all
women's prison in new jersey have just
become pregnant you wonder how that
happened well turns out those women had
sexual encounters with another inmate
who was a biological man passing as a
woman now some people predicted that
this would happen and they were laughed
at
mocked and attacked as bigots
karadanski's at the very top of that
list she said this years ago on our show
she's the president of the u.s
chapter of the women's declaration
international author of the book the
abolition of sex how the transgender
agenda harms women and girls and we are
happy to have karadanski back here
thanks so much for coming on i'll never
forget the first time and i it had to
have been for at least four years ago
when you said if we keep going down this
path we're going to have biological men
in women's prisons and you were right
absolutely thank you so much for having
me you know though
the story that's happening in new jersey
is obviously horrible for so many
reasons we need to not have men being
housed in women's prisons but a couple
takeaways from this that i just want to
point out are first of all the state is
not getting away with this by telling
its residents that they are housing men
in women's prisons what they are doing
of course is telling the residents that
they are housing so-called transgender
women or trans women in women's prisons
suggesting that there is some sort of
sub-category of women that is called
transgender women or trans women and
it's not true the fact of this story
shoots the shoots a hole right through
the trope that trans women are women our
society has been taught that we are
supposed to say and think that trans
women are women but obviously that is
not true because the individuals that
are the focus of the story impregnated
women and every thinking adult no matter
what the president of the united states
has to say on the matter knows that
there is no category of women who can
impregnate women so i really want to
thank you for highlighting this story
and i also just want to point out that
this is not just a problem in new jersey
this is a problem across the country i
know that we have talked previously
about how the state of california
recently enacted a law at the end of
2020 which went into effect in 2021
which mandates that men be housed in
women's prisons on the basis of their
so-called gender identity if they say
that they are women washington state has
a similar policy however this is not
just happening in blue states this is
happening across the country as far as i
know 49 states plus the district of
columbia have some form of law or policy
in place that mandates the housing of
men in women's prisons
why is it left to you and jk rowling and
a couple of others to point this out
where are the physicians you know
perfectly well the way you're saying is
true the biologists who know it every
bit as well why are they going along
with this when they know it's a lie
so the entire medical establishment in
the united states has been captured by
so-called trans ideology and what i
really want all americans across the
political spectrum to understand is that
trans is not a civil rights movement to
protect a marginalized community of
people it is a multi-trillion dollar
industry that is pushing this it is
paying the medical establishment it is
paying most media outlets it is paying
our government it is paying our schools
it is at all levels elementary schools
through college to push the idea that
material the material reality of sex
does not exist and that what is more
important than the material reality of
sex is so-called gender identity this is
all being pushed by a multi-trillion
dollar industry in the guise of a civil
rights movement it's all a lie
and these are the people providing her
medical care it's really scary when you
put it they are i know someone i know
someone who is a medical student right
now and she is horrified about what's
being taught i do just want to say
really quickly there's something that
has been announced in the past couple of
weeks called the women's bill of rights
this was drafted by members of the
women's liberation front and by members
of independent women's voices supported
by my organization women's declaration
international as well as concerned women
for america and i really hope that one
of the members of congress introduces it
thank you so much i hope so too great to
see you we'll be right back
[Music]
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight